Jennifer Lopez just teased her upcoming
Super Bowl halftime show and it is
everything when to be a great show what
can I tell you we're gonna try to give
the best Super Bowl show ever you know
okay so if you're like me you don't care
who's playing in the big game on
February 2nd because it's really all
about J Lo's halftime show with Shakira
thank you thank you well get ready to
freak out because on Sunday JLo posted
this video to Tik Tok showing a group of
kids learning some sick moves to her
2011 song on the floor oh and it gets
even better
JLo captioned the clip take on the
challenge and danced to on the floor
with me i'll reshare some of my faves um
do we think she means she'll reshare
them at the freakin Super Bowl okay so
I'm gonna take a second to calm down but
in the meantime here's what JLo told et
about her upcoming performance I'm ready
are you ready yeah I'm ready I'm excited
about it yeah I mean it's me and Shakira
she's carrying half the load I feel good
so you're like I'm good I'm good I'm
good no I'm excited we've been working
on an amazing show for everybody and you
know it's a few weeks out go back to
rehearsal right tomorrow morning it is
what it is and when et was with JLo over
the weekend she admitted her body is a
little beat up from the rehearsals but
she's not complaining I was thinking
about this earlier life like you know
what I'm saying like this is you've
taken us on this ride writing about what
do i I'm not gonna complain about except
a few sore muscles from rehearsal
nothing I mean my life right now is just
so amazing my personal life you know my
kids everything everything's just in a
great place and I feel really lucky of
course this recent tick-tock teaser
isn't the first time we've gotten a
little sneak peek at J Lo's Big Show
back in December J Lo's bo Alex Rider
because being the supportive afbf that
he is took to Instagram to share a video
from her half-time rehearsal yeah that's
JLo with a bunch of girls who apparently
are set to perform with the singer
during her Big Show later that day he
shared another video of his fiancee
dancing to some music
during a break how proud are you very
very proud very proud that same month
Jennifer dish to ET about how all that
halftime prep was going not me I don't
have that much time no you're already a
deep in rehearsal we're starting we're
starting yeah so how are you mapping
things out or what is the process of
mapping out a show like the Super Bowl I
don't have to remind you the millions of
eyes they have in a minute it's just
about for me I'm obviously gonna try to
put together the best show that I can
but also it's about having fun you know
just being up there and enjoy again
staying present in the moment and
enjoying all of the wonderful things
that are happening right now this I mean
it's such an achievement though so what
are some elements that you're really
hoping to put into your Super Bowl
performance I wouldn't give away any of
those secrets right now oh come on Jen
no sorry
people have to develop it a little bit
more maybe Alex gonna make it a little
cameo of some oh there was no talk about
yes
listen it's J Lo's world and we're all
just living in it I can't wait to see
what she brings to the Super Bowl and of
course you can count on et to keep you
up-to-date on all of her teasers along
the way so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]